today on the matt walsh show a new
report shows how government handouts
have enabled record numbers of
able-bodied young men to opt out of the
workforce entirely and indefinitely but
why would young men want to opt out of
work in the first place isn't that the
real problem we'll talk about that today
also the virginia's governor's race will
be um settled tonight terry mcauliffe
made his closing case to voters last
night and i don't think it will prove
effective plus the supreme court refused
to step in and hear a case from a
catholic hospital that was sued after
refusing to perform a sex change
operation and sleepy joe falls asleep at
the u.n climate summit finally atlanta
braves fans are still doing the tomahawk
chop
even though the media has repeatedly
informed them that it's racist and they
need to stop but is it really racist
we'll talk about that today and much
more on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you know the holidays are basically
upon us are approaching quickly anyway
and you got to start thinking about
don't wait till last minute start
thinking about what kind of gifts you
can get this holiday season and this
christmas and here's one legacy box
legacy box is simply the best way to
preserve your past send your legacy box
filled with old home movies and pictures
they'll do the rest digitizing your
moments onto a thumb drive the cloud or
dvd it's just like magic if you're if
you're like most people there's one box
that you'd run back into your burning
house to grab and it's that box filled
with video videotapes film reels photos
those are sentimental meaningful
irreplaceable moments you can save these
from being destroyed by floods or fires
as i've already revealed i would run in
to the burning house to save a dog or a
panda but i would go i would run right
past the dog and panda and grab my box
of old home movies instead and then on
the way out i would apologize and say
sorry sorry rex i had to get this
instead uh but why leave it to be
destroyed you just got to use digital
you got to use legacy box you send it
all to them they digitize everything
they send it right back to you they make
it easy to make it simple so
take advantage of this deal right now
legacy box is giving our listeners early
access to their black friday sale visit
legacybox.com
walsh to unlock any uh an exclusive
discount for our black friday sale
that's legacybox.com walsh for their
best deal of the year again
legacybox.com walsh so i had what has
become a familiar experience over the
weekend i ordered a pizza from a pizza
place that shall go unnamed i was given
a delivery time of 40 to 45 minutes
after an hour with no pizza in sight i
called to check on his progress
no answer called again 15 minutes later
no answer just not answering the phone
at all after an hour and a half a little
bit more than that actually finally the
order arrived with profuse apologies
from the delivery guy who explained that
no delivery people showed up to work at
the location where i ordered
and uh he had to be called in from a
different location to pick up the slack
because there were none at that location
this experience would be just a minor
inconvenience and um not worth
discussing or telling you about plus i
used to be a pizza delivery guy uh back
in my younger days so i i tend to you
know give a lot of leeway i'm very
um you know i'm very generous in that
way i'm not gonna get mad about pizza
being late the problem is that
this is symptomatic of a much larger
problem which can be seen and felt all
across the country the worker shortage
crisis is especially pronounced in the
restaurant and hospitality industries
which means that i've encountered it
quite a bit with all the traveling we've
done in recent months almost no hotels
anywhere have enough housekeepers on
staff to keep the rooms clean that's a
fact that hotels will tell you now as
part of the standard spiel upon check-in
uh where they tell you well we're not
going to send in housekeepers if you if
you really need something you can call
us and we'll try to send somebody up to
you room service is now almost entirely
a thing of the past not enough workers
to keep it going this is not just
anecdotal either here's a report from
vox today it says
employers in almost every industry say
they're struggling to find workers but
the situation's especially severe in the
leisure and hospitality sector while
workers in these industries are getting
paid more than ever it still doesn't
seem like enough bars restaurants and
hotels across the country
are posting signs advertising open jobs
or asking customers to be patient since
they don't have enough staff in august
the latest available month for openings
and turnover data from the bureau of
labor statistics there were a near
record 1.7 million open jobs
in leisure and hospitality ten percent
of all jobs in the sector and a record
of nearly a million people quitting
and this is happening again as it said
right there
while wages are higher than they've ever
been
now this may be a especially significant
issue in the leisure and hospitality
industries but the situation isn't much
better in most other industries
big question is
why is this happening
what do we do about it
and as far as that goes there are a
number of important factors that can't
be ignored one of them is vaccine
mandates i mean that's not helping
that's driven some employees out of
their positions or kept qualified
applicants away to begin with
but that's not the primary issue here
especially because this is a problem
that predates
most of these mandates
the greater issue seems to be that a
large and troubling amount of americans
have decided that they don't want to
work at all
and government has made that lifestyle
feasible for them has made that an
actual lifestyle choice
something that you can select from the
menu of options one of them is
i'm not going to work
so here's the daily wire it says a new
analysis argues that government welfare
policies encourage able-bodied men to
opt out of the labor force
many point to weak wage growth
technological change or international
trade as potential explanations for the
low labor force participation rate among
young men which has dropped from 97 in
1955 to 89
in 2020 however republicans on the joint
economic committee argue in their
reconnecting americans to benefits of
work report
that a significant share of the young
men who receive handouts from the
government are voluntarily disconnected
from work it says only 12 percent of
inactive prime age able-bodied men said
they wanted a job or were open to work
only 12 percent
among men who are inactive for reasons
other than disability retirement
education or home making 41 personally
received government assistance one key
piece of evidence that suggests labor
force trends are driven largely by
workers not employers is that the
decline in prime age labor force
participation has been mostly voluntary
as told by the men themselves three out
of four disconnected men
say they do not want a job
three out of four and only 12 percent of
inactive prime age able-bodied men said
they wanted a job or were open to it in
2014
if more men are genuinely choosing to
stay home with the kids go to school or
retire early policy makers
should not be concerned but that's not
that's not
the full explanation here the report
goes on to explain how welfare programs
especially those without work
requirements
or with work requirements that are easy
to fulfill even without actually trying
to find
work you know you just got to put in the
application
show up for the interview not put in any
effort and you can keep the benefits
rolling
the report says well those that's
largely at fault here
keep in mind that this only tells us
about the trends leading up to
our current state of affairs
doesn't factor in the covid related
handouts which enabled millions of
additional people to stay home for
months on end many of whom have shown no
particular desire to return to the
working world
the end result leads to a lot more than
pizzas being delivered cold and hotel
towels not being changed what lies at
the bottom of this flight from work
this rejection of work i think
is
despair and purposelessness
this is both the cause and the effect
so it's a self-perpetuating problem it's
a cycle
vicious cycle
people don't see any real purpose to
their existence
they don't see any reason to live and so
they're happy to uh merely exist
floating by
desiring only to be made comfortable and
kept entertained
now it's not that getting a job
delivering pizzas
would itself
give your life purpose
that's not the point
it's that working to provide for
yourself and your family if you have one
is what you do when you have intention
and purpose in your life if you have
goals if you have ambition you would
rather get a job even a menial job
and then get at least one foot on at
least the first rung of the ladder
there's also value in work for its own
sake work is a necessary part of life as
i've explained before life is work
your existence requires work to maintain
there's no getting around that
and if you're not going to do it
then someone else will have to do it for
you
but there is there is dignity and honor
in standing at the helm and steering
your own ship
rather than having the government do it
or more precisely having the government
enlist the taxpayers to do it
against their
will but the catch-22 here is that
people in despair
who could most benefit from the dignity
of work
are also least likely to care about
something like dignity or to pursue it
for its own sake
so that is the problem that lies at the
bottom of this and this is what we need
to be talking about
we can we can look at all the economic
factors we can look at wages and wage
growth all of these things
um that's really window dressing
on the real problem which lies at the
foundation of all this
is that we have
millions of people not just young men
but lots of young men especially
who are content who are fine with
staying at home
watching tv
on the internet playing video games
whatever
that that's a life as far as they're
concerned
that's that could be their entire life
and they have no desire for anything
anything beyond that anything greater
than that
that's what we need to start speaking to
is that despair and hopelessness
that's in the hearts of so many
americans
until we address that problem and talk
about that problem
none of these things are going to get
any better
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i tell you about my pillow all
the time and why do i tell you about my
pillow because uh because it is
it just it works what's a pillow
supposed to do it's supposed to help you
sleep still have a great night's sleep
and that's what my pillow does and
that's why i uh i depend on it now it's
almost like an addiction i can't sleep
on anything but my pillow products
um and uh that's why if you have not
tried my pillow you got to try it now in
my pillow they want to give back to our
listeners you can get great discounts on
all my pillow products if you go to
mypillow.com right now and click on the
radio listeners specials
get deep discounts on my pillows
mattress toppers towels and so much more
for example my pillow is offering a buy
one get one free offer on giza sheets
these are top quality sheets that you
will love all my pillow products come
with a 60-day money-back guarantee and a
10-year warranty it's nice to have the
money-back guarantee you're not going to
need it but you do have it there go to
mypillar.com and click on the radio
listener special for the buy one get one
free offer on the giza sheets and use
promo code dailywire at checkout or you
can call 800-651-1148
you'll also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including pillows
slippers the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets all of that if
you go to mypillow.com and enter
dailywire or call 1-800-651-1148
and tell them the daily wire sent you
that's 1-800-651
all right so uh well as you can see by
the way we've got the the thanksgiving
decorations here um that's because this
is this is a thing now on the show now
we're going to have decorations for
every holiday and i and i personally
um i'm happy that i came in on monday
and we had the thanksgiving decorations
because there are lots of people these
days that say well as soon as halloween
is over and we get into november that's
when you put the christmas decorations
up and i got nothing against christmas
decorations i mean when it's time for
christmas decorations i want
i just want it to look like christmas
exploded in here i want to have a giant
mechanical
santa right behind me waving on camera
the entire time but it's not christmas
season yet
it's not even advent yet
and what i don't like is how
thanksgiving
gets cannibalized
by christmas every year so we are
actually doing
thanksgiving decorations on this show
and uh i do appreciate that
all right so
uh the virginia's race comes to a head
today as uh as voting is underway
and i'm
not an optimistic guy you know you know
that
and uh i've come this far without making
any predictions
so there's really no reason to make it
now
but i will anyway i i like glenn
younkin's chances i think he wins
um tonight
and uh i think all of the
all the trends are in his favor
all of the the momentum is in his favor
he's got all of the excitement
and going up all the way to the last
moment when they were making their their
final pitches their closing cases
so terry mcauliffe speaking to a smaller
crowd and a noticeably less excited
crowd let's hear what his closing case
to the people of virginia
was as as we know cultural issues and
education became the central focus of
the um of the race
so terry mcauliffe
finally speaking to education closing
argument
here's what he has to say
we've got to diversify our teacher base
here in virginia 50
50 of the students in virginia schools
k-12 50 are students of color
and yet eighty percent of teachers are
white we all know what we have to do in
a school to make everybody feel
comfortable in school so let's diversify
so here's what i'm gonna do will be the
first state in america if you'll teach
for five years here in virginia in a
high demand area i've got to be
geographic or coursework
we will pay room board and tuition at
any college any university any hbcu here
in the commonwealth of virginia
[Applause]
so that's that's what terry mcauliffe
has for you
there are too many white teachers
so terry mcauliffe is saying listen
virginians i've heard you i understand
parents you're worried about education
you're concerned about your kids you're
concerned about what they're being
exposed to at school you want to make
sure they're getting a real education
okay
and so i've heard that and so what i'm
going to do is make sure that there are
fewer white teachers
because he believes apparently or he is
he is uh duty-bound to believe he is
required to believe
as a democrat
that this is the sort of thing that
parents wake up worrying about
he thinks of parents in virginia and
across the country they wake up every
day thinking about man
you know sending their kids off to
school putting them on the school bus
waving goodbye the parents are sitting
sitting there thinking oh man i'm really
worried that
there's just too many white teachers
at my son's school that's that's my
concern
yeah mom and dad sitting around the
kitchen table
you know honey i'm really worried that
uh junior is uh
he's just he's around too many white
teachers
i'm worried about the racial makeup
of of of the teachers at his school
that's that's what i'm concerned about
that's what terry mcauliffe imagines
so that's his that's his closing case
um it wasn't just that by the way he
also brought in randy weingarten
spoke at terry mcauliffe's rally last
night
randy weingarten is the the president of
the largest teachers union in america
she's also the most despised figure in
education
in the country
i mean she's one of the main reasons why
schools stayed shut down for 18 months
in many places
she never wanted to open the schools
back up again
so all of these parents who had to deal
with you know quote-unquote remote
learning their kids were on zoom classes
for 18 months not learning a damn thing
randy weingarten largely responsible for
that
like there there are
i have not talked to a single parent
who has anything positive to say about
their kids experience on zoom classes
for a year or 18 months or however long
it was depending on where they live
i haven't talked to a single parent
about this conversation with many
parents about the zoom classes and how
that went i haven't talked to a single
one who said yeah that was great i'm
really happy my kids went through that
this is this is all my child needs it's
just to sit in front of a computer for
seven hours and stare at a computer
and have this disembodied head speaking
back to them
giving them busy work and assignments to
do
so randy weingarten largely responsible
for that one of the main voices at least
promoting that form of education and uh
uh terry mcauliffe brings her in
totally despised
figure in education brings her in
as his last act before before the um
before the polls open
incredible and i'm happy to see it
because i think again i don't want to i
i'm afraid i'm going to eat my words on
this but i think that was the nail in
his coffin metaphorically speaking uh i
just
if everything happens
this is a big if
if everything's above board
and everyone is playing
fair for the most part
i don't see how terry mccullough wins
and once again that is a big if
especially because
um we we know what the democrats in
virginia did only a few days ago
by sending some democrat operatives to a
glenn younkin campaign event with tiki
torches pretending to be white
supremacists and that was exposed
almost immediately and then and then
linga project came out and said oh yeah
just kidding it was a practical joke
wasn't that funny no that was a fraud
that they attempted
and now there's a question about whether
or not another fraud was attempted
because um these pictures from a glenn
this is this was glenn younkin's rally
in loudoun county huge turnout
uh people very excited
and this is the picture that the media
went with you can see it here on the
screen this is the picture the media
went with well all the blue checks on on
twitter
were passing this particular image
around
and there's a glenn youngkin event and
then you could see there somebody in a
denim jacket and a cowboy hat
with a confederate flag prominently
stitched onto the back of their jacket
now
i will say
if this person
if this is real and this is someone who
sincerely just wears a confederate flag
jacket
um i don't care
i really don't care and it doesn't it
has no it doesn't say anything about
glenn younkin
so if one person decided to show up to a
glenn younkin event in a confederate
flag a jacket that doesn't mean anything
at all
but you do have to ask questions about
how sincere this actually was especially
because this now here you can see in the
other picture here's where this guy is
standing
so he took a position
right leaning against the press pen
so he's got like his calling card that
he's showing off to the press right
where they are where they're all
standing with there you can see there
with their cameras and he's showing it
to them saying hey guys check this out
can we go back to the other let's go
back to the first picture though
can we look at this okay you see this
denim jacket looks like a brand new
jacket no scuff marks or anything it
looks brand new
um that
the confederate flag
print on the back the patch also looks
brand new
bright red
so it looks like he just got this jacket
just put the patch on the back
excited to go to the glen young route
he's also got the the cowboy hat on he's
with some woman who also has a cowboy
hat
the only cowboy hats in the crowd
because this is again louden county
virginia
okay this is not this is not texas where
you see cowboy hats all over the place
and then the other strange thing
is that he's right there in front of the
media's got the confederate flag thing
going on
we have no pictures of the front of his
face
nobody in the media stopped this guy
apparently to ask him
what's your name what are you doing here
tell us about yourself why do you have a
confederate flag pin uh patch on the
back of your jacket
now if this was a really sincerely a
glenn younkin supporter
you don't think the media would be
tripping over themselves i mean
literally tripping over themselves
dog piling over one another to get to
this guy
get his face out there get his name and
get him on camera
talking about why he has the confederate
flag and why he as a you know supporter
of the confederacy is also supporter of
glenn yonkin
you don't think they'd be incredibly
eager to get all that on camera
but oddly enough the media discovered uh
restraint and they just they decided to
respect this man's privacy isn't that
nice of them not show us his face not
get his name
now it's
pretty pretty obvious this is another
this is uh
would seem to be another intentional
fraud committed by someone
and so that really is their closing
argument it is fraud
trying to label glenn younkin as a
racist
um and uh and then
randy weingarten and there aren't enough
black teachers
that's terry mccullough's closing
argument
uh i don't think it'll work for him i i
do think glenn young can wins the
excitement
it's it's you can't
you know excitement is something that's
it's not easy to
conjure
by sheer force of will
it's something that republicans have
historically not been very good
at i mean donald trump
obviously has been able to get people
excited other republicans have not been
able to do that
and what's really encouraging about
glenn youngkin
is that he's been able to sort of close
that excitement gap
and generate some on a smaller scale
because he's running for governor
virginia not president but on a smaller
scale generates some of that sort of
trumpian
uh excitement
but he's doing it by talking about the
issues
he's not doing it by aping and imitating
trump's style he's not doing it by
talking about trump
so i hope this is not only a win in
virginia but but maybe
a little peek into what a post-trump gop
might look like
where it's people are mobilized they're
excited we're talking about the culture
talking about education we're talking
about issues that parents really do care
about
and wake up thinking about
and crucially
it's a gop that is not entirely centered
around one personality around one guy
because the issue with trump is that
when he's on the stage
um when he's in the conversation he is
the conversation he needs the only
everything is centered around him and he
wants it that way when he's there
but that's never been the way to have a
lasting cultural movement
that's structured around one personality
if it's going to mean anything
and if we're going to make any real
changes in any real cultural headway it
has to be much bigger than that
much bigger than one guy so maybe we're
getting a taste of that virginia we'll
see
okay next from nbc news the supreme
court on monday turned down an appeal
from a catholic hospital in california
that was sued after refusing to perform
a hysterectomy for a transgender man
transgender man
i.e uh a a woman
who
calls herself a man the court's denial
issued without comment says the lawsuit
sends the lawsuit back to state court
for further proceedings uh against the
hospital and voids for now the issue of
when claims of religious freedom can
trump anti-discrimination laws
um
justice clarence thomas samuelito and
neil gorsuch said that the court should
have taken the case
you notice who's missing from that list
amy coney barrett
justice cavanaugh
were not interested in taking this case
um
there what they said to the hospital is
hey you're on your own
now this is when it comes to religious
freedom not just religious freedom but
freedom in general
because you don't have to be in fact i'm
a little
i wish they had taken this case and this
is a religious freedom issue
but
you know
i'm i'm concerned about making this only
a religious freedom case because when it
comes to
you know
quote unquote sex change operations what
they call it now gender affirmation care
you don't have to be religious to oppose
that
if you're a rational
morally decent person you're opposed to
that
you should be opposed to mutilating
people
in order to conform their delusional
perception of themselves in order to
conform their body to their delusions of
themselves
no matter what your religious
affiliation is including if you have no
religious affiliation you should be
opposed to that
so it's not merely a religious freedom
issue but it is also that
and amy coney barrett
who pretty much every conservative was
excited about myself included
not interested in taking the case
kavanaugh also less of a surprise
doesn't want to take the case
now we've got two big abortion cases
that are making their way through the
court right now that are being uh
the court's court is deliberating over
right now
including the law down in texas
and uh i'm very hesitant to make any
predictions there based on the kinds of
questions that the very the justices are
asking as the arg are as these arguments
are presented but
there have been potentially a few red
flags from amy coney barrett
in fact at one point i think she she
asked a question
um
referring to roe v wade as a
constitutional right in her question
so accepting that premise in the
question that she asked
maybe that was a slip of the tongue
maybe she just she wasn't being
uh careful enough in her wording
but if we're hoping for roe v wade to be
overturned it's it's uh
it's concerning to hear her
accepting it as a constitutional right
i don't know
this is something that i think for a lot
of people it was thought a lot of
conservatives that the the supreme court
picks
were trump's greatest achievement
but the way things are heading right now
it's it's looking like these might end
up being his greatest failures
gorsuch has been surprisingly the most
solid of the three but uh
so far barrett and kavanaugh have been
huge disappointments
all right let's see uh what else we got
here
uh
elon musk this is from yahoo it says
elon musk the world's richest man
challenged a united nations official's
claim that just a small percentage of
his wealth could help solve world hunger
musk was responding to comments by david
beasley director of the un's world food
program who repeated a call last week
following an earlier tweet this month
asking billionaires like musk to step up
now on a one-time basis
beasley specifically called for action
from musk and amazon.com co-founder jeff
bezos the the two men atop the bloomberg
billionaires index
just six billion dollars could keep just
six billion ah just six billion just six
billion dollars could keep 42 million
people from dying beasley said if the
world food program using transparent and
open accounting
can describe on this twitter thread this
this is from musk now he says if they
can describe in this twitter thread
exactly how six billion dollars would
solve world hunger i will sell tesla
stock right now and do it
um and so far
no one has been able to meet that
challenge
that's a fair question
if you're saying money can solve the
problem then how exactly will
it's not good enough to say well we'll
give the money to this program like how
exactly will this money have that effect
and
i'm pretty skeptical of that myself
because
poverty is not merely a money problem at
its root not merely
it's a problem of choice and human will
and when i say that i am not saying that
poor people wake up and say i want to be
poor and they make the choice be poor
but that one way or another very often
choices lead to poverty and often
often these are not the choices of the
impoverished people
okay so for example
much of world hunger in other countries
like in third world countries
is due in large part to corrupt
political regimes
dictatorships
okay so it's not simply that the
countries don't have the money
but that corrupt regimes choose to keep
their people oppressed there's a whole
lot of hunger and starvation in north
korea
that is not merely a lack of resources
it's that the resources are hoarded by a
corrupt political regime
so that's
a choice made by people not the poor
people but by the corrupt politicians
and dictators and people in charge
bureaucracies
homelessness in america
is driven almost exclusively by drug
addiction
drug addiction itself is not a choice to
do drugs to begin with is
uh the other part of that picture is
mental illness
which of course again is not a choice
but what makes mental illness lead to
poverty are the you know quote unquote
choices made by those afflicted now
these may be choices that you can't be
blamed for because you have a mental
illness but the point i'm simply trying
to make is that these are all problems
that cannot be solved by throwing money
at them
because very often in many of these
cases
the issue is what people are doing
so if you have uh
if we have poverty in a third world
country that's run by a corrupt regime
well you can't you can't simply throw
money at it because it's not going to go
where it needs to go
and we certainly know that with
homelessness
you know there's a great number of
homeless people
on the street right now
that you could go and hand them a
million dollars
and
they'd still be homeless a week later or
the next day i mean they would they
would just be homeless still
because the problem isn't that simple
so money money is is a part it's
one of the tools that can be used to
address this problem
but it's not what fundamentally causes
it
but
uh
as always
you know we're looking for the simplest
possible answers and we're also looking
for for you know easy targets and
villains
and so if we see a lot of poor people in
the world and then we see rich people
it's easy enough to say well it's their
fault just you got the money give it to
those people and everything will be fine
it's not that simple i wish it were that
simple
but but it isn't and life rarely is
okay here's something that is kind of
simple i think um it's a video
taken by a mom who's was very proud to
take this video and put it online for
everyone to see
uh she
is letting her daughter know that um
that that she the daughter will soon be
able to be vaccinated
and uh this is supposed to be a
heartwarming video based on the
young girl's reaction but i have a
i feel a little bit differently about it
let's let's watch this
this is my daughter hi
she's nine
we're about to blind react to something
okay what does that say
hold on dear
what does it say
that the coven vaccine for kids is
so next week should be
clear for kids to 5 to 11.
what does that mean for you
i can
go with my friends yeah
i can finally you know go outside
go to stores
i'm excited
i'm excited
i thought i was gonna be like in a
couple months no it's next week
i love you mom
she's white you need to get vaccinated
okay
no she's why you need to be in prison
you
monster
this is another another of those tough
ones that i almost regret playing as
soon as i play it because i can't
like
i'm running through in my head all of
the words and that i want to use and
things i want to say
and i have to just no can't say that
can't say that i can't say that and i
have to be very careful and selective
you know if you think i'm harsh in the
things that i say i don't there's like
95 percent of it especially when it
comes to these parents and what they do
to their kids
95 of it has to be left on the mental
cutting room floor because i can't say
it out loud
uh but that is monstrous and this this
is a woman who should be in prison she
should have her kids taken away from her
um
locking your child in a home
for 18 months
i mean listen to what the girl said she
said oh it means i can go outside
this is the kind of thing that in any
other context
if you heard and we do hear about cases
of kids being locked in their home
by their crazy
uh abusive
barbaric
and
parents
any other context when you hear that
you think well this is this is a this
this is horrific abuse
these are kids that need to be taken out
of the home they need to be removed from
the home forcibly they need to be saved
from the clutches
of these barbarians
in any other context
except in covet somehow it's okay
i mean taking covet out of it for a
second
let's just imagine
that exact same kind of video
except it's uh it's the flu
the flu which as i've said a million
times
is a much greater threat a more lethal
threat to children like that young girl
there than covet is
and yet if covet never existed and you
heard of a parent who kept their child
locked in a home for 18 months for fear
of the flu
wouldn't even let them go play outside
with their friends
you would say that parent is crazy
this is not simply uh you know a
parenting choice a judgment call no
that's insane
and you are a danger to your child
well it's no different here how could
this be any different this is worse
this is worse because because covet is
less of a threat to the kids
and somehow we just accept this and
meanwhile that
what makes all this all the more uh you
know just
an additional morbid irony here
is that
that mother
is uh extremely overweight
okay
so
she has her child locked in in a home
really to protect herself
because she doesn't want the kid to
bring covey back to her
and so for her own sake to keep herself
safe she keeps her kid locked away and
yet she's that concerned about her
safety uh but and she's willing to
deprive her child of a childhood
take everything from she will take
everything from her daughter rather than
deprive herself of milkshakes and french
fries
she's so concerned about her health but
she's still gonna have the milkshakes
and french fries every day
okay you get a physique like that by by
eating fast food like every day i mean
you have to try
you have to try to put that much fat on
your body
not trying to be mean well i am trying
to be mean to this particular person
anyway because they deserve it
but yeah you you got to try i mean you
you have to put in at least
no effort whatsoever when it comes to
your diet and fitness
and so she's putting in no effort
willing to sacrifice nothing for for
health
but to her daughter she says you got to
sacrifice everything
repulsive
horrific terrible okay uh what else we
got one other thing i want to show you
this is from as we get
as we get closer to christmas and uh
thanksgiving is cannibalized and we just
skip right over to christmas we're going
to see a lot of these kinds of posts and
this is from this is a viral post from
someone named dave
and um it says it's november 1st the war
on christmas has officially begun
jesus wasn't white yep that's right your
son of god is not a white man he's as
brown as me
and there's a image of what he imagines
jesus must have looked like and you know
uh
darker skin and that's that's that's his
uh image of what jesus would look like i
just love these kinds of posts as i said
as we get closer to christmas we're
going to see more and more of this we're
going to see ah jesus wasn't white and
oh jesus was a socialist jesus was a he
was an illegal immigrant and a refugee
and they could start throwing all that
stuff out at you
and um
but especially when it comes to this
this this this
dunk that they attempt
a couple things about that
first is that
well number one
white the term white
would have had no meaning
in the context of the ancient world
okay so if you had been walking around
in jesus time
and you had gone up and referred to a
white person they would there was no
idea what you're even talking about
they would think you were they would
think you're talking about a ghost
if you said i just saw a white person
they would run away because they think
you're talking about a ghost
they would have no meaning
so to say that there was a jesus wasn't
white well yeah that's just a category
of person that wouldn't have meant
anything to anyone back then
but more precisely more to the point
no christian
cares about this
this is something you exclusively find
on the left
among non-christians
obsessing over jesus's ethnicity and
race
you know jesus wasn't white
so
no one cares
i have never in my life met an actual
professing christian
who talks about this or cares
or is it at all focused on it
um
you know because jesus was
jesus is the son of god come to redeem
mankind that tends to be the focus
not what his skin pigment happened to be
but we know on the left i mean they for
them
the first thing that matters about
anybody including jesus is their
demographic you know first we gotta we
gotta we gotta look at the all the boxes
that are checked off
this everything is demographic it's all
about identity
and so they assume that we have the same
uh the same focus when we don't
all right um
and yeah i mean you know in in
churches where
traditionally there's a lot of white
people maybe you'll see images of jesus
where the skin's a little bit lighter in
churches where there's a higher portion
of non-white people you might see images
of jesus where skin's a little bit
darker again who cares
we don't know exactly what jesus looked
like at all in fact
uh we have no illustrations
he didn't pose for any portraits
and so depending on who you are and what
you look like and you're kind of
imagining jesus in your head he might
reflect you a little bit
um
and that's just a natural thing that the
mind does but we we don't attach any
significance to that that's something
that they that they do on the left and
that's and people who are again
non-christian
all right so
let's move ahead now to read in the
comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this is from gm
referring i guess to the video of the
that we played yesterday of the pilots
who were recording that ufo sighting
says attention bros this is your captain
speaking this is there's like this
wicked orb pulse setting in the sky lmao
just don't y'all freak out and let's go
brandon
uh yeah that is that's kind of that's
the uh vibe i got from those captains
who
sounded like normal guys but again i
don't want normal guys as pilots of of
an airplane that i'm on
uh late mnf says you want your pilot to
look and sound like sully sullenberger
yeah exactly that's exactly what i want
in fact sully sullenberger
and he's the pilot who landed that uh
plane right in the hudson
not an easy thing to do
and i think it's not a coincidence that
he was like this a white-haired guy with
a mustache in his you know i think like
in his early 50s at the time
i think that's what all pilots should
look and sound like i think in fact
first of all the mustache when i when i
get a look at the in the cockpit
and i see a pilot with a mustache i
immediately feel safe
man or a woman by the way no
discrimination here
i think that should be a legal
requirement
and yeah i do want them to sound i want
them to have kind of that vibe sound
like like i said someone from the 40s or
50s
good enunciation
these pilots are here sometimes i mean
it kind of it it freaks you out because
they sound half asleep and they're
mumbling you know they come over the
intercom there's their attention but
you can't understand what the hell
they're saying
i want to know that you're engaged up
there that's the point
um elizabeth says the football draft is
unethical the humanity of the players is
completely put to the side as teams and
fantasy players argue back and forth and
weigh the odds however it's resoundingly
not racist all races of players get the
same treatment it's like the feminists
who call everything rape when your only
moral standard is racial every social
problem you see becomes race obsessed
well you're correct elizabeth that if
the nfl draft and the process of
recruiting players was dehumanizing
then you would be correct and that
dehumanizes everybody and so it wouldn't
be racial even then but uh you're wrong
in calling it unethical i mean this is
these are people who are paid
a lot of money to do what they do for a
living
and um
their physical fitness
you know
the things that they're able to do with
their with their bodies on the on the
football field or whatever sport they're
playing that's obviously very relevant
and so you need to be able to measure
that
whatever you want to do for a living
you're bringing some kind you're
bringing skills and
hopefully certain skills and qualities
and traits to the table
and your employer to decide if they want
to hire you they have to have some way
of measuring those skills
and in football this is just how they do
it so i think the quality humanizing
is absurd and by the way if anyone wants
to he dehumanize me in that way
by giving me a 40 million dollar
contract i will take it
i will i will be a slave in that way if
the daily wire if they decided they
wanted to dehumanize me and enslave me
with a 40 million contract i will i will
humbly accept it
um
daniel says the cancellation from this
episode was by far the best cancellation
of all time i was laughing so hard i was
literally crying thanks matt i needed
that well shame on you then uh daniel
shame on you
what else do i have to do to explain
that this is a solemn subject of joe
biden pooping himself allegedly
he says this is not fodder for jokes and
laughs
i already i canceled you once now i
gotta cancel you again and you're banned
from the show that's what you get
um
let's see uh
pf araby says the pilot in that specific
video from the cockpit pretty clearly
says let's go braves who are in the
world series now it would have been
awesome if he actually said let's go
brandon though
uh
yeah that's that's an important point
also i mean we talked about this the
ridiculous controversy over a pilot
allegedly saying let's go brandon well i
think it's it's probably the most
relevant to point out that he he didn't
even say that it sounds like he actually
said let's go braves
but if he had said let's go brandon i
agree with you i wish he had um if he
had it would it wouldn't matter
alex says matt loved how you compared a
woman not taking a husband's last name
is like not sharing bank accounts can
you please explain in a more articulate
manner better than myself why a husband
and wife having two separate bank
accounts and even a combined one for
bills is incredibly dumb and shows a
sign of distrust in your spouse because
this has become common among several
people i know love the show uh yeah it
is dominance and destructive to your
marriage i think and um
if it's a complete separation of
finances now i know there are some
couples i've talked to who
they'll have like separate you know
little checking accounts where they keep
a little bit of spending cash for the
week kind of a weekly allowance deal
and um and they they do that just just
as a way of
keeping track of their discretionary
spending throughout the week
i mean i think that's fine as long as
they're not actually separate accounts
like these are accounts you both have
your names on it's just that you've
chosen to
separate you you've chosen to use them
in this way and organize your funds that
way obviously no problem with that
um the issue is when
when when finances are completely
separated as you do find increasingly
in uh in married couples
and this again i you know to me this is
not as severe i know there are a lot of
people see it in the reverse where
having separate finances is a more
severe separation than um having
separate names i think it's not as
severe but it's still it's still not
good
because it's a lack of trust
that you're showing in your spouse
and you're also just showing a
determination
to in this significant way in a
financial way to live a separate life
and there's nothing wrong with living a
financially separate life from other
people
it's just that if you want that then
don't get married
if you still want to have your financial
independence i hear that too well i want
to be financially independent
so why did you get married
i want to be financially independent i
want to have my own name
okay i mean you had that already before
marriage so what is it exactly you're
trying to get out of marriage
the whole point of marriage is that
you're you're coming together as one
unit
and sharing your life together if you're
not willing to do that then i would say
um
you shouldn't be getting married and
then and then the other big issue
the reason why a lot of people do this
is um they're looking towards the future
and they're thinking about contingency
plans and hey just in case we get
divorced it'd be a lot easier if we had
our finances separate ahead of time
so you're getting married
but you you're keeping one foot outside
the door
you know and you're keeping your coat
there and your shoes there right you're
keeping everything ready just in case i
got a split real quickly
you can't have a marriage that way if
you go into a marriage that way
preparing ahead of time
for the moment when you leave
you'll leave
the only way to to to have a marriage
have a happy marriage and to have a real
chance of staying together
is if you've ruled that possibility out
to begin with
you know you hear this story about uh
cortez
when he came to you know uh
what is now modern day mexico and uh he
had this small band of conquistadors and
they eventually conquered the aztecs uh
with the help of of of some of the
neighboring tribes
who were happy to be liberated from
aztec rules so they wouldn't be
sacrificed and have their you know have
their hearts cut out anymore but anyway
um before he made that march inland you
hear the story about how he burned the
ships
you know basically saying to his men
there's no turning back now you have to
be fully committed to this because
you're not you're not going anywhere
we have no way of escaping the only way
out is through
and so in that one specific way
um i think marriage is kind of similar
you sort of burn the ships and you say
this this is it we're together now we're
not we're not leaving any escape plans
and hopefully you know
having hearts ripped out and all that
kind of stuff hopefully there's no
similarities there to marriage but you
never know you know there's nothing that
can drain you uh both
financially and mentally and emotionally
than having a lot of debt especially a
lot of high interest debt to pay each
month and if you do have that you know
the cost can become overwhelming and it
can be easy to fall deeper into debt it
becomes this vicious cycle uh but look
it doesn't have to be that way with a
10-minute call to american financing you
can learn about options to get out of
debt faster with help
from your mortgage you'll get a much
lower rate and you'll only have one
manageable monthly payment to focus on
makes it a lot easier for you
financially and also as i said just uh
mentally as well and out of all these
things to worry about it's a strategic
solution that could save you up to a
thousand dollars a month plus tens of
thousands in the long term imagine the
difference that can make then call
american financing for a free mortgage
review find out just how much you can
save there's no pressure no obligation
no upfront or hidden fees you can even
skip uh two mortgage payments so uh if
you wanna take advantage of this you
gotta call american financing and you
gotta do it now eight six six five six
nine forty seven eleven that's eight six
six five six nine forty seven eleven or
visit americanfinancing.net
all right let's get now to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so tonight with any luck the world
series will come to a close um if the
braves beat the astros in game six
they'll have won the series and the
world champion trophy and best of all
the baseball season will finally be over
it's not that i hate baseball anytime i
try to watch it i can't stay awake long
enough to develop any strong feelings
about it but i do think that baseball's
a fine activity for children especially
fat children who need some physical
activity but aren't fit enough to play a
real sport yet i think it's great for
that
my main issue with baseball as a
spectator sport is that it involves far
too much standing and sitting
at any given moment during any play 95
of people on both sides have nothing to
do
the entire team on offense is sitting
down except for the guy at bat then on
defense the the majority of the guys in
the field
won't be involved in the play even if
the batter hits the ball
if i want to watch people standing or
sitting around bored and despondent
interspersed with brief moments of
moderate physical exertion i'll go to
the dmv or the post office or something
so it's just a long way of saying that
baseball has some problems
these are all practical problems and
problems that can't be fixed except by
introducing you know i don't know you
could introduce tackling to baseball or
maybe by arming the outfielders with
paintball guns i'm not sure what that
would do exactly but
i'm just thinking out loud brainstorming
or else we might need a constitutional
amendment to simply abolish baseball
entirely uh the media on the other hand
has been focused on trying to find other
problems in baseball aside from the fact
that it's you know boring as hell
for them of course
the problem is not entertainment
for them it's always about race
and as the season is coming to a close
they are in a mad dash to find some way
to racialize baseball the fact that the
braves are involved has provided them
with obvious fodder so here's cnn says
native groups and advocates are
demanding that the atlanta braves
eliminate the tomahawk champ chop symbol
and gesture from its branding and game
day traditions saying the team is
perpetuating racist stereotypes as the
braves take the national stage in the
world series leaders from the native
community said this week it's past time
for the braves to join other
professional sports teams such as the
cleveland uh guardians and washington
football team in removing offensive
imagery and mascots which they say
reduce native people down to caricatures
now you'll be shocked to learn that joy
reid over on msnbc agrees that it's
racist for braves fans to do the
tomahawk chop then again she thinks the
fans if they're white are racist no
matter what they do i mean they're
racist when they breathe they're racist
when they walk into the stadium the
racist when they put their pants on in
the morning the tomahawk chop is just
the racist cherry on top of the bigoted
cake so let's listen to joy reid
the world series between the atlanta
braves and the houston astros is
happening now shifting to the stadium in
atlanta for the next three games which
means viewers across the country will
soon be subjected to a particular show
of fandom that has roiled baseball for
decades
and that's the tomahawk chop correction
the racist tomahawk chop a synchronized
movement of the arm by atlanta fans at
home games a gesture and chant promoting
stereotypes caricatures and frankly
hatred of native american people the
chop gets its world series spotlight
starting tomorrow as other teams are
retiring such appropriation the
washington football team ditched its
former name a racial slur we will not be
repeating here and the cleveland indians
banished their extremely offensive logo
and also changed their name to the
guardians this week baseball
commissioner rob manfred came out in
defense of atlanta saying quote the
native american community in that region
is fully supportive of the braves
program including the chop but yeah no
because native americans and allies have
protested the chop for at least 30 years
including actual native american
baseball players like cardinals reliever
ryan helsley a member of the cherokee
nation who was forced to pitch amid the
chop when his team faced the braves the
national congress of american indians
responded to manfred saying native
people are not mascots degrading rituals
like the tomahawk chop that dehumanize
and harm us have no place in american
society
well yeah i'm sorry let's back up for a
second the tomahawk chop promotes hatred
of native americans
is that what you think these fans are
saying to themselves as they move their
arms like that damn native americans i
hate them damn them
um i find that unlikely in fact if you
if you hate a certain person or certain
type of person you wouldn't want to pay
tribute to them in that way you also
wouldn't want them as a mascot
if a mascot is supposed to be some kind
of degrading insult
why doesn't any team name themselves i
don't know the nazis how about the
atlanta nazis
maybe that should be the new name
i mean if that's the idea right with a
mascot you're supposed to be insulting
somebody
but if they did that i'm quite sure that
the joyrides of the world would combust
from pure outrage accusing the team of
promoting and celebrating nazism and in
that case she would be correct that's
because a mascot is meant to be a
positive thing a promotion a celebration
indian mascots and chants are a tribute
to native americans not an
insult why do native american words and
imagery make for good sports mascots
well because
native american culture was a warrior
culture that's what the tomahawk chant
uh and chop specifically harkens back to
and pays homage to
indians were warring people that's a
historical fact there's no reason to
hide from it or deny it
the effort to remove all of the native
american themes from sports is part of a
larger
uh uh you know effort to sanitize indian
culture and its history
to feminize and sterilize it
to paint the indians as helpless weak
victims rather than the formidable
forceful
and ferocious people that they often
were
this is something that the left wishes
to do in the past and the present as
native americans of today are portrayed
as petty you know limp sorts of people
who are constantly crying over sports
mascots somehow gravely injured by team
names and stadium chants
i don't think that the majority really
are so fragile
and for anyone of any racial or ethnic
group who is that fragile to be that
upset about a team mascot
it's all the more reason
not to bend to their whim and give them
everything they want
and so the people complaining about
racism here are of course cancelled but
i also have to say that for non-racial
reasons uh baseball as well
is canceled so all of that is canceled
and we all we tied together in a nice
bow as baseball hopefully comes to a
merciful clothes tonight we can only
pray and that'll do it for us today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle our audio
is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show terry
mcauliffe faces the music in virginia
encounters by playing the race card plus
joe biden falls asleep during a vital
climate change conference that's today
on the bench bureau shall give it a
listen